Sasha Baron Cohen or SBC if you're nasty
introduced himself to American audiences
back in 2003 with the Ali G show but it
was the year 2006 that he released Borat
and you couldn't walk 3 feet without
hearing my wife my wife unfortunately
he's been laying pretty low these last
few years and here's why can she come
for desserts absolutely not and neither
can you Sasha Baron Cohen made Ali G
Borat and Bruno household name but as of
late
2023 all three of those characters are
dead figuratively speaking Baron curan
originally ditched his Alig in Borat
alter egos in 2007 following the release
of Borat King in the castle King in the
castle I have a chair I have a chair and
in 2016 Baron Cohen reminded fans that
Borat was still retired and made it
clear that Bruno was too nowhere in the
script does it say he pauses for an
inordinate period of time that made it
all the more surprising when Baron Cohen
did bring Borat back one more time in
2020 for borat's subsequent movie film
while fans might have loved his
character's pranks especially the ones
that put bigots and homophobes on blast
they were also dangerous according to a
2021 interview with NPR Baron Cohen said
that he had to Dawn a bulletproof vest
while filming the newest Borat movie out
of fear he might be shot welcome to
America baby sbc's com is deliberately
outrageous and he's accused of sometimes
going too far but he's not pushing
buttons for no reason in a 2006
interview with rolling stone about Borat
he said I think part of the movie shows
the absurdity of holding any form of
racial Prejudice whether it's hatred of
African-Americans or of Jews in other
words the joke isn't always what Borat
says it's what he makes other people
feel like they can say in my country
they take them and they take them to
jail and finish them take them out and
hang them yes what we're trying to get
done here half five one Infamous segment
of the Alig show showed Bora leading a
bar full of people in Tucson Arizona in
a sing along to the fake song Throw the
dud down the well Baron Cohen recalled
that was a very controversial sketch and
some members of the Jewish Community
thought that it was actually going to
encourage anti-Semitism but to me it
revealed something about that bar in
Tucson and the question is did it reveal
that they were anti-semitic perhaps but
maybe it just revealed that they were
indifferent to anti-Semitism still just
because his comedy has a purpose doesn't
mean people aren't allowed to be
offended from lgbtq groups who think
Bruno is a little much or the entire
nation of Kazakhstan still dealing with
his bull I get a clock radio he cannot
afford great
success Sasha Baron Cohen stunts go hard
but not everybody finds his Antics funny
in September 2008 flamboyant fashion
reporter Bruno crashed the famous Milan
fashion Fashion Week and as the national
newspaper Lara commented violated the
sacred rituals of high fashion yes
rituals because those virgins aren't
going to sacrifice themselves to Prada
drawing a show by Spanish designer
Agatha Ruiz DEA Prada Baron Cohen and
crew used fake passes to infiltrate the
backstage area where he wed havoc in a
fullbody velcro suit he somehow ended up
on the catwalk with a whole crapload of
clothing stuck to his body and proceeded
to strut his stuff before organizers cut
the lights
puno for house he was forcibly removed
by security and had to explain himself
to the Italian police I would have loved
to be a fly on the wall for that
interrogation remember kids you can
always do an Italian accent it's never
racist the disruptive stunts were shown
off in Cohen's Bruno but not everyone
appreciated Baron Cohen's gate crashing
for the sake of his art a spokeswoman
for the national chamber of Italian
fashion told the telegraph after Cohen's
Fashion Week stunts everybody is talking
about it some people were very angry and
annoyed when you pull the kind of stunts
that disrupt disparage and genuinely
cause disarray you're bound to find
yourself languishing in legal hell case
in point Sasha Baron Cohen is a lawsuit
magnet okay let's speedrun this mother
the executive director of Des valy
Charities unsuccessfully tried to sue
the people behind Bruno for upwards of
$25,000 claiming a prank that Baron C
and aort at a bingo game left her
confined to a wheelchair a Palestinian
Roser settled a slander suit against
both Baron Cohen and David Lesman the
defamation of character after being
portrayed as a terrorist in the movie
two South Carolina college students a
Baltimore driving instructor and a
Macedonian singer will tried to sue over
issues taken with Borat as did the
residents of the Romanian Village of GL
and that's just a start in addition to
upsetting basically every Eastern
European village ever Baron Cohen
managed to offend the country of
Kazakhstan by portraying its people as
backward and bigoted a prominent kazak
Cinema distribution manager told Reuters
we consider this movie offensive a
complete lie and nonsense pissing off an
entire country might be impressive but
it's just another Tuesday for this guy
that manager added quote it's a shame
that some Americans will probably
believe what they see there however
Kazakhstan eventually brought into that
old adage about all publicity being good
publicity and Deputy foreign minister
rard alv even invited Baron Cohen to
Kazakhstan so Borat himself could see
that quote women drive cars wine is made
of grapes and Jews are free to go to
synagogues what is the most popular
thing in the
world
music no at the height of his INF fory
it was basically impossible to get an
interview with Sasha Baron Cohen the
same cannot be said for Ali G Borat or
Bruno who are more than happy to give
their two cents about well anything in
my country only time you can have more
than five women gathering together is
either in a brothel or in a grave okay
uh as you can imagine this didn't
exactly give viewers an inside look at
the man behind that glorious mustache
before Baron Cohen promoted the dictator
on today in May 2012 the actor had only
done an astonishing two interviews out
of character but as with all things SBC
there was a method to his madness he
explained well the movies that I did up
until now they involved real people and
so we wanted to limit the exposure for
lawsuits at the moment I think I have
the Guinness world record for most sued
actor in history but basically if people
saw that I was me and that Borat was not
a real person beforehand then they could
injunct the movie and shut the movie
down it would have been like a
Scooby-Doo villain pulling his mask off
half through the episode how do you pull
a fast one on your unsuspecting victims
if you've been basking in the media
Spotlight the whole time these days
Sasha Baron Cohen doesn't shy away from
the camera as much but that doesn't mean
he's given up on screwing with them
that's one of the craziest things I've
ever seen in my life in the immortal
words of your insufferable film snob
friend Hollywood ain't what it used to
be and clearly Sasha Baron Cohen agrees
and he thinks that Tinsel Town would
have passed on his early films if they
were being pitched today he told the
telegraph I think Studios of a becoming
more reluctant to take big risks they're
all owned by multinationals now and have
to show profits I want to be a star in
in a huge Hollywood
movie can you make that happen no still
unlike your insufferable film snob
friend Baron Cohen doesn't think
Hollywood's gotten too far off track he
explained if it wasn't for the Academy
Awards Studios would only make movies to
make money because of the Academy Awards
Studios make movies to be good as well
Baron Cohen might appreciate the academy
for keeping quality in Hollywood but the
feeling is certainly not mutual the AAR
landed himself in hot water with the
powers that be not only once but Twice
first by ruining Ryan SEC suit on the
red carpet and later by making an
appearance as Alig G unforgivable crimes
we know the actor admitted I think my
publicists got into a bit of trouble and
I doubt if I'll be invited back going to
move it on a little bit we've come a
long way since 2006 a lot of the jokes
that Sasha Baron Cohen makes in the
first Borat film simply wouldn't fly
today even though it's easy to assume
that there's no line that the actor will
cross that's not exactly true there are
plenty of lines and new ones are being
added all the time despite Sasha Baron
Cohen's best jokes being made with
strangers on the street and clueless
interviewed subjects his characters are
often fleshed out in the writer's room
talking about the brothers Grimsby which
was completely scripted and suffered
terribly for it he elaborated we will do
a joke that makes us laugh in the room
and we say can we do this joke and then
there is a discussion of is it moral to
do and is it ethical to do is it too
far oh God this is disgusting with
characters as clueless as Borat
outrageous as Bruno and just painfully
stupid as knobby Grimsby their jokes
often do end up going too far he
continued there are a lot of jokes that
I would not make I am continually
filtering stuff that is too much too
much is a perfect description of Borat
and Bruno but given The Changing Times
Baron Cohen has felt the need to ca
correct that might not be doing wonders
for his brother Rand though which is
built around being over the- toop
offensive May the patriarchy go to hell
nice nice don't man slain to
me when Sasha Baron Cohen released Borat
in 2006 it was one of the biggest
surprises of the Year despite not having
a massive reputation Stateside Baron
Cohen's flick raped in a bonker's $262
million worldwide on a budget of just
$18 million not only that but everyone
from your neighbor to your boss was
constantly quoting it respect is
nice this surging popularity made Baron
Cohen and his characters seem like an
extremely attractive option for
Hollywood Studios however his newer
films haven't replicated the lightning
in a bottle or rather the baron and ice
cream truck success of the first Borat
[Music]
again his next release Bruno in 2009 had
a strong opening day but enthusiasm
created almost immediately it did less
than half of what Borat did domestically
in the US and Canada $60 million with
more than half of that on the opening
weekend his 2012 film The Dictator had a
rough opening weekend at just $4.2
million and failed to top the $60
million Mark domestically his Worst by
far was 2016 s brothers Grimsby which
lost money on a $35 million budget for
some reason the promise of seeing Baron
Cohen climb inside an elephant wasn't
enough Baron Cohen's most recent feature
20 20's Borat subsequent movie film was
released directly to Amazon Prime for
streaming and even though Amazon said it
did well that was disputed almost
immediately the members don't lie unless
they do Baron Cohen has simply never
been able to replicate the success of
Borat and it seems to be making some
studios weary of any big budget projects
with his name on them lots of Sasha
Baron Cohen fans would love to make an
unwitting appearance in one of his
movies as long as they're able to keep
themselves from saying something
horrifically offensive the comedian is
found himself in legal trouble several
times for showing his subjects true
colors and some of those subjects are
the most powerful people in America
Baron Cohen is the Lee Harvey oswal of
comedians after all he's always setting
his sights on politicians lots of
elected officials would like nothing
more than to go back in time and stopped
themselves from talking to one of his
characters going back to Borat in 2006
Baron Cohen filmed a scene with former
Congressman Bob bar junr after which bar
had the comic thrown out of his office
um my wife uh she make this cheese very
nice she make it from a milk from her
teeth but that was nothing compared to
his Antics in the 2018 Showtime series
who is America which skewered numerous
politicians Sarah Palin complained that
she was tricked into doing an interview
and made fun of and former Vice
President Dick Cheney was fed into
signing a fake waterboard kit a former
state representative from Georgia Jason
Spencer resigned from his position in
the government after he was in an
episode and yelled racial slurs while
walking around in his underwear finally
former George and US Senate candidate
Roy Moore sued Baron Cohen after being
made to look like a pedophile on the
show when Baron Cohen revived his most
popular character for 2020s Borat
subsequent movie film he caught former
New York Governor Rudy Giuliani in what
seemed like a compromising position with
a young female interviewer igniting a
massive controversy what's going on here
look at this guy I forbid this Union
Baron cin has certainly rubs some
politicians the wrong way maybe just
enough to scare off some Hollywood
Studios before Borat and Bruno got their
own movies there was the Ali G
showa check this out yo back in the late
1990s and early 2000s Sasha Baron Cohen
made a name for himself through his
character Ali G a rapper with few
talents and even a fewer manners as
funny as some of Ali G's Antics could be
there were many critics of his alter ego
who found the character offensive and
accused Baron Cohen of mocking Black
Culture check it today we is chatting
about medical ethics in 2007 after the
release of Borat Baron Cohen announced
that he was retiring Ali G's character
but it didn't last 9 years later he
brought the character back for the 2016
Academy Awards with Olivia wild as his
embarrassed hostage and without the
prior knowledge of the academy the stunt
received mixed reviews with some critics
saying that it was outdated nevertheless
he once again revived the rapper in 2021
during a standard performance that went
largely unnoticed considering Baron
Cohen's never- ending quest for
attention it appears that he's intent on
bringing him out once again reports
indicate that he will be devising a new
standup routine featuring Alig but only
the man himself knows for
sure for many Baron Coen fans it's
welcome news to see a long dormant
character return but there's a reason
why the comedian first hung up the
beanie and goggles all those years ago
the political and social climate in
America has shifted dramatically since
Ali G's Heyday in the early 2000s and
the character's cultural appropriation
of Black Culture might not go over too
well with some audiences today it might
be best that Alig stays in the 2000s
along with denim skirts and Dane
Cook